most definitely America's the most
wasteful country in the world it's a
country of abundance which is why we
don't have a food culture you know I
don't know if we're ever going to have a
food culture but because we produce so
much food and I have so much excess of
everything particularly food I don't
know if you know America has never been
hungry really hungry for a long period
of time like many other countries grand
were not as old as other countries but
almost everywhere else like food is
cherished and people are knowledgeable
out when I lived in Japan I was like oh
my god everybody knows everything about
food what fish is in season two the
vegetables and the product is so well a
product and the quality of the product
is so high and you can eat well even on
the cheap there everything is affordable
even affordable food is delicious and
that was that was sort of what was a big
moment for me watershed moment you could
say I was like wow food doesn't have to
be great on a fine-dining level the
wealthy super wealthy people don't have
to eat well and America like to enjoy
food depreciate food to sort of really
enjoy it is almost viewed as snobbery
and elitism whereas in other countries
that's not it's like wow like this is
what this is part of our culture this is
part of our heritage just as part of who
we are is cooking and enjoying you know
food and it's not the case here it's
about hamburgers and hot dogs and pizza
and french fries
it's totally overrated because that's
what people grew up eating you know most
part for the history of the world and
you know I think chef Keller said it
best like it's easy to cook the fillet
mignon it's easy to cook the last turn
it's really hard to cook something that
use normally thrown away and to make it
delicious and that's peasant cooking and
that's where real food comes from is
from people that didn't have the
luxurious ingredients they had to make
do with what was best around them and
it's funny that it's like deemed cool
cooking but like that that's real
cooking to to the cooks and to us and a
lot of guys that you know coming up with
the recipes are working on the recipes I
know that we have a fried veal
sweetbreads but like you know we're
trying to make something that's normally
delicious every one less sweetbreads
almost but like say pigtails or or
trotters or or even like stomach that's
that's hard and I think the not that's
more Americans right now in the culinary
world or at least different media I
think they enjoy it more because of the
novelty of it all that it's it's
different and it's sort of chic but
there's nothing shika bout stomach or
tribe or pig's head there's nothing sexy
about that a cool you know that's what
you should be doing anyways you know
you